okay four people joining this livestream
we are in the late days of getting
version 12 ready to ship and for some
reason we seem to have a trailing tail
of stuff to do with database connections
so we have yet another discussion about
this and we're just talking about how to
document specifics a particular day
databases and the answer is that this
function relational database oops this
link though it does work um this will
have a thing next to it that says
listing of database types okay does that
make sense just like if you look at the
paid for import it will have something
that says see that listing of formats
makes sense okay so that's guys database
folk you understand this
I'm sorry Carlo could you respond please
yes yes yes absolutely I mean it's gonna
be a bit more sparse since we support of
course yeah okay it's just gonna be okay
so each of those pages will then go to a
special type that will be in this list
presumably you guys need to specify what
the sections of that should be making
sense yes now in terms of where we get
the examples from for something like an
Oracle database I don't know do you have
a way to do that yeah we'll come up with
examples
I'd almost done because we can't expose
an Oracle database to the world how can
those examples work I mean though they
won't work for other people that's right
okay so you'll freeze the examples yeah
I mean there is one way to do things
which would be in that we could include
the dump and people who are really
really willing to try them out they can
try no no because I need that no no
that's hopeless let's not worry about
that three examples just need to be
mocked up as long as they you know yeah
Rosen still on how about the examples
sitting in some dedicated AWS instance
for that we can look at it but I don't
think the problem is that there is a lot
of people who just looks for real war
databases hosted for free somewhere and
if somebody finds it even if not a lot
of people use this within the Wolfram
language
somebody's gonna write the exercises
somewhere and then maybe five years from
now it becomes really popular and now we
pay a lot of money well if the database
is a rather trivial then somehow I doubt
that this will be an issue well for
example you can make that work if you
can make it work but what about the
licensing of things like an Oracle
database I don't know it's not how that
company can get the free date year was
the Community Edition okay well fine if
you can make it work make it work but I
wouldn't hold this up to that and I mean
for the initial release we can just have
the examples be frozen I mean I felt
okay also we gotta move on yeah I agree
okay all right you have that page open
can you look at the three four items
that are intact devised in relational
database
what about these things uniqueness
constraint those are the things so
basically before they were under the
column properties but since you can have
a uniqueness constraint that has more
than one column included so we moved
them up to the table properties and we
change the names so this is the stuff I
added call on a live stream is pointing
out that SQLite can absolutely have
examples and yes we are intent of yeah
we do have examples with SQLite yes okay
I don't understand this thing here
uniqueness constraints what is what is
that that's unique sensibilities it's
something where you say you have two
simplest case you have one column and
you cannot have repeated items in that
column how are we giving me uniqueness
constraints and by the way I certainly
it's down below columns involved the
Ender constraint thing okay that's the
uniqueness constraint right think of is
unique together something that involves
the work well because what you do here
is that justify two or three columns and
you say those three columns are unique
yeah but most cases you will have one
column only
so most cases yes
what the heck does this mean look why
isn't this cold
what was it cold previously please it
was called the unique but it was just
true or false on one column since you
can have multiple columns that are only
unique together then no no wait a second
specifying go ahead now how I was going
to ask if you are sure that constraint
that unique is a constraint it all began
yes yes yes yes this is a constraint it
can also be an index but it's mostly a
constraint on buckets okay so hold on
this is saying no look this is a silly
name if this is called foreign keys mr.
foreign keys table level property okay
so unique columns or was another name it
I was using I don't know what's the
right-hand side of this the right-hand
side look be Beloit's an association
that contains columns and constraint
name what is the constraint name
whatever is just name just it's just a
random string that you have to choose
when you said it
what do you mean that you have to choose
when you said it I explained okay when
you're a stranger come straight got a
name and you can yeah we got to explain
it here you're not explaining it to me
explain it I mean in general that's the
same for foreign keys whatever you have
funky e that's also constraints and it
can have name we haven't documented are
you talking about what are you talking
about okay you say general in SQL when
you create a new constraint whether it's
a foreign key or it's a uniqueness
constraint you I understand but you had
a very simple way of doing this which
was to specify for a given column that
everything on the column should be
unique right yeah
the problem no no no wait a second wait
a second now you've got some complicated
thing with constraint names and so on
which you're asking everybody to put in
that doesn't make sense but okay so
though I'm not asking any
to put it in because this is what comes
out of the inspection the problem is
that in in in its most general form a
constraint does not involve one column
it might involve three columns so this
is the general way of specifying it then
it is true that maybe in 80% of the
cases constraints involve a single
column but it's not always okay so what
are they constraints on there of values
right the list yeah yeah yeah so yeah if
you have something you have something
that is like I don't know okay I get it
I get it I get it I get it so is this a
correct description yes okay
now what do you mean by the name of the
constraint here well what why is there
any constraint on this one this is
primary key used to access the
properties of the primary what is the
primary key constraint what about where
the hell did the word constraint come
from here
there's no constraint it's that look
this is the primary key for that the
parameter Yi's are constraint I don't
care let's get rid of the word
constraints it just confuses everything
this is a property of the primary key
right
now what's this the name of the
constraint is that the name of the
primary key is that we have 30 minutes
to wrap up everything you guys need from
me okay so you seem to have made some
mess here again what do we weave coming
cien in general these things foreign
keys primary keys uniqueness and so on
they are implemented through agile
concept that is called constraint there
are different types of constraints okay
what does the name of the constraint
mean with respect name of the constraint
means it's just a handle so that when
you want to tell the database that you
want to delete that constraint you just
call it but there's no what are you
talking about a constraint there's a
primary key with a name right yeah but
the priority is a form of constraint I
don't care
why is that what what is the constraint
name got to do with the primary key the
primary goal fool and the constraining
can be called foo underscore fubar it's
it's just you know a string of this
functional sorry have some examples of
this functionality because it's
difficult for me to just talk about this
in abstract ways I mean this is stuff
deeply internal stuff that you get out
when you inspect it will not you will
not see this when you're working with
MySQL but when you work sorry with the
SPL light but when you work with MySQL
then on inspection you need to detect
those things and they adenine I mean we
didn't drop the name from the relational
database but it has it okay and its
values whose combined values are taken
to be unique is that right
yes okay I don't understand this name of
the constraint I just don't understand
it but we got to move on so I would like
you guys to come back and you know our
node maybe you can try and work through
this yeah I mean we we need to interview
the one
default because take a look at examples
and see how this actually you know
affects users I mean if we're just
documenting you know a large number of
very internal things then we need to
think about if that's what we really
want to do I mean how is this exposed to
users how do users you know use the
documentation to do something I mean it
doesn't really matter much now because
we do not create databases but suppose
you ELCA means back if you want to
inspect the Postgres database and then
you want if I say associated with the
primary key is that going to help
anybody or is that incorrect no that's
correct
okay the name of the constraint
associated with
the name of the uniqueness constraint is
that right
yes I don't think this is really good
but but I mean since this is mostly just
inspection of an existing database
that's perhaps what we can say the
problem is that if we perform an
inspection with them putting that stuff
and then you cannot recreate the
database elsewhere okay all right I
asked the last detail is also important
because we didn't talk which last detail
a relational database has one option
includes related tables is this a new
page that you've created here
that's a reason we discussed this right
we discussed this function
what what are you talking about here
okay
to this page
I just created one hour ago so sorry I
was made I've not seen this one yet okay
so this now becomes it's relational
database right thank you okay so this is
include related tables the default is
this is the way that we document these
things
the default is I just notice that in
some cases where there was only one
option yeah I know we sometimes do that
okay um oh gosh don't tell me this is a
bug this is a bug here I think you need
to include yeah that last most column
yeah okay all right so um whether to
include tables pointed to effectively
bike foreign keys is that right yeah but
how do we say that more officially than
pointed to by um whether to include
tables associated with foreign keys that
okay yeah I'll say so I mean it's it's a
bit confusing because that it seems that
you're dropping any table that has
foreign keys on the other hand you you
know that include tables containing
foreign key no good tables defining
foreign keys it's it's more like
mentioned in foreign keys okay
referred in foreign keys
referenced by foreign keys yeah that
worked and what does it do if it's true
so if it's true it gets the fully
connect the connected component start
from the tables you mentioned so that
that relational database object will
have those tables included in it why on
earth is this not tagged as experimental
can you make sure please um whose
project managing is caller
Andre yeah okay could you make sure
everything in this cluster is tagged as
experimental please okay all right we
got to move on here you want to talk
about the error conditions and then we
got a loop back to the really horrifying
work on on entity okay all right so what
is the question here the question is
that right now we have a mixture of
stuff that either fails with a missing
or gives a useless result silently or
issues a message and then returns a
missing and we would like to unify these
with failure objects okay also the
reason why we want to do this
steven is that in many cases we feel
that missing is just inappropriate end
result for these operations well okay so
what are you proposed to do that I mean
let's look at the cases you've looked at
here I mean this doesn't seem to be a
proposal you the thing about slot has
nothing to do with anything
so so the proposal is so except for the
last case where you you still have some
structure and so the missing makes sense
for the unknown property I think that
all the other cases the trial return
missing invalid query and the ones that
say what was that unknown property or
something like that so should be failure
if invalid query or something so what
you saying yeah something like that
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
so that's a reasonable thing but if the
if it can't find the entity value but
this mixed case
clearly gives trouble right because this
mixed case you know what you'd be
signing up for there is that would have
to be failure then instead of missing no
no no because that's effectively just
you're trying to select from the data
set something that is missing in that
case the problem is when you start
saying something like short by something
that doesn't exist and right now buting
entities fail silently you don't fail
they just sort by nonsense they start
balancing so they don't sort and add an
reassure message on the database side
I'm sorry what are you saying what so
can we example would like filtered
entity class words like full larger than
three that thing is just asking me is
missing larger than three and it returns
an empty list and you don't know what
went wrong okay so you're saying
multiple different things
first of all generate messages in that
case yes why not
you should generate messages when
something goes wrong when when when the
individual thing would produce failure
you should produce a message even if in
the end you won't see the failure
because you've removed because the
actual symbolic object is filtered out
and the failure is no longer present so
messages son really not the best ways to
signal errors okay
would you please like to explain what
you are proposing what dozen yes we are
proposing that in a number of such cases
we return a failure object which
contains enough information inside to be
able to process it further
programmatically okay so we're gonna it
so let me let me re reinterpret that
claim okay you say whenever something
goes wrong whatever it is inside
generate a failure object as the output
is that correct so instead of giving a
null list here you would give a fair
object here is that right yes yes look
at this case here okay it's not
something in sign that's going wrong in
something outside its well but it could
be something inside it could be that
this that this sub element has an inside
problem
that I just basically I'm doing this
inside that sub-element right so the
sub-element in other words right I know
III don't think so because in general
when something goes wrong you know the
cases in the sections above it's
something that involves the whole entity
class so you don't have it any sub
element anymore I understand but you can
obviously have something like this where
you're mapping over multiple pieces
where something goes wrong in one piece
but not in others well it's obvious it's
go viously got to be possible right
because all I have to do is take this
thing here and just put that in a list
right if I've got a list of this and
something else then I'll get that
behavior why are you putting the list
okay listen listen listen if you can
generate something like this whatever I
am certain that there's a way inside
your calculus so to speak to generate
something where part of it has an error
and part does not okay and you got to
deal with that case so let's assume that
there is a way of doing that I do not
believe that this calculus is such a way
if you have an entity function on the
second area but not in the first time
you okay whatever
whatever doesn't matter it doesn't
matter the the the point is you got to
deal with the case where some meaningful
output is generated but some part of the
output errors out but I want to say that
that will never happen for a second just
a second just a second we got to deal
with that case right the case that you
were otherwise describing is whoops
something has gone wrong the whole thing
is an error yeah what I was saying is
that in general in SQL you will always
get everything going wrong because we
guarantee that every time you do one
call 20 value it's one call to the
database so if I just can't compile that
thing to ask you out the whole thing is
always going to splat okay you know what
I don't know partially knit I'm sorry I
don't believe it I think that there's a
that's the case for the current
implementation I don't believe that
they'll never be a case where like this
case here where it turns into multiple
database calls
we have a good reason for for making
entity value be atomic
in terms of transactions to the database
and I don't want to break that design
for meaning okay okay okay look look
okay you're saying that at this point at
least you're either gonna get a
meaningful a completely meaningful
results or you're gonna get a pure
failure object is that correct and that
this case we will not support right
that's what you're saying all right soon
there is an edge case where you simply
request some missing property where you
will get missing and it's okay it's not
a failure in that case when you for
example simply go in the entity value
and ask for a list of properties one of
them is invalid
all right so that's a little bit of
slippery slope here okay so you say most
database queries most things that have
eventually compiled into a database
query where something goes wrong you
just return failure correct yes
but in the one slippery case where the
thing that went wrong is you requested a
property that doesn't exist you will get
missing instead is that correct
yes okay so what's the structure of the
failure objects that's what we wanted to
discuss with you a proposal no I mean
the thing about the the failure is that
it can more or less mirror the current
messages so like specificity what do you
think should be in the failure the
failure might be quite complicated you
might want to unpack it and you might
want to programmatically unpack it yeah
absolutely absolutely that's the
advantage so for example when we say so
if you look below there are some
examples where you say stuff like cannot
compile plus with arguments it's the
second example under no comparable
function but before you try to sum a
string with the number in that case I
can give a lot more stuff if it's
failure look at the structure of what a
failure object has in it okay wait wait
wait wait wait wait it has a tag okay so
that's a failure type so is are all
these going to have the same failure
type I think so it should be database
error but the sub type or the specific
reason for failure could be a part of
the sock spec and should be different
for different failures fine but I think
I think we all need okay so this is the
typical thing message template message
parameters right which is the thing that
is a human readable failure yes you're
in real bill error okay then what you
propose to do is to add lots of other
parameters here and possibly sub
associations which are a computable
version of what went wrong is that
correct yeah but that's really the case
I mean if you recall we introduced
failure with interpreter we designed it
together so an interpreter already has
extra information
doesn't go in the message things like
input things go kalo I understand but
you have to design as essentially a sub
language of database failures do you
have that sub language and is there an
obvious way to do that yeah we already
have
I mean internally we're using failures
now the question is how do we align with
Tony we like so the question like if a
column doesn't exist that and that
returns a missing in the entity function
that is really not a problem for for
building entities because you're
actually comparing missing but we're not
proposing to return failure for anything
to do with built in entities right never
so we can do an example with where
you're like one is for example network
connectivity goes wrong which is the
same of database connectivity it goes
wrong okay pretty slope okay we're
talking about the tag database error
right
so are you proposing another tag for me
I don't think I don't think let Tony
speak about this Tony a you do you need
some kind of failure object with a
different tag
Tony whoa so the current status assessed
was summarized well that there are
missing objects and it's a it's a
suggesting that we change them for
failures no no I'm just wondering you
know we are going to introduce an
inconsistency between database SPECT and
okay how about you actually listen here
I'm sorry I you know gosh guys come on
okay what I'm hearing you propose is
number one a missing value is simply
missing whether it's from the database
or whether it's from the built-in
knowledge base okay or whether it's from
Sparkle or whatever else there is a
different situation which is a malformed
or otherwise unex acute able database
query is that correct or beauty
knowledge space malformed query no no no
could mean at least two different things
it could mean syntactically correct with
an invalid property or it could mean no
that's a different case that's the case
of a missing property that I've been
sold as being not a failure not
generating a failure now what what if
the property's missing is I read the
first two examples with the filtered
antique glass that is trying to go to a
property it doesn't exist you see that
those think large is five and the one
with sorted empty glass are ten minutes
guys we have ten minutes and we have a
lot more than ten minutes worth of stuff
this this is not good you know this
meeting was added okay we still have to
do we still have all this I think Todd
and I can continue working on this I
think we can come up with a workable
proposal here Stephen okay but but
entity is a big mess right that
documentation page was a big mess let me
tell you what my my suspicion is about
this failure object thing okay I mean I
think well Tony maybe you can comment do
you believe that any of your built-in
knowledge-based queries should return
failure objects so there is a proposal
to make whenever an invalid property was
used make that more prominent because it
might be easily missed
so I Grievous the database group and one
proposal was to issue a message I'm not
sure what implication if we instead of
issuing a message to start using
failures no no no no no no no no stop
stop for a second okay okay if there is
an error we should su a message the
question is what do we return do we
agree that we should issue a message
whenever there's a failure we should
issue a message whenever there's an
something goes wrong in the database
query or in the lookup from the
knowledge base we should assume essage
yes or no no okay why not because if we
already give a failure as a result no no
no you're saying that you expect
everybody to look at the know in in some
program that is you know digesting the
output yes people will never know that
there was an error they'll do some tests
they'll never know there was an error if
they don't want the message they can
switch the message off I'm sorry but
looking at messages is the opposite of
what ones here it's a bad way to handle
errors
we've discussed that for many times no
no wait a second wait a second there's
two different things one is to have a
computable representation of the error
right we agree we want that
that's what failure provides right yes
okay the second question is do you
signal to people that an error has
occurred for people who are using things
interactively do you signal that by
generating messages right and what I'm
saying is I think we should signal that
by generating messages I don't see any
reason not to the problem is that the
interactive use starts collide it was
programmatic you used to but but if you
have messages and it's in some deep in
some server somewhere nobody will ever
see the messages fine well but how how
would you make not see the messages if
you what what okay because the message
is because the thing is in some API
somewhere you're never gonna see the
messages the messages don't go to the
return value of the API the only thing
that goes to return value of the API is
a failure object well but the message is
still a side-effect so if we already
returned the failure optical why would
we signal the error in cars otherwise
people it's the same reason okay if I
say you know there's a million examples
of that okay come on somebody on owed
Todd somebody speak up please I totally
agree with Stephen I mean you're
cleaning you're worried about messages
percolating up from deep within some
program and users are scratching their
head as to why am I seeing messages I
mean there is always quiet for that but
I mean we pretty much do have a rule
that says I mean these are real failures
right these are something that a user
probably might want to know happen right
they're not just right I mean if I if I
try to open a file and it fails a
message comes up I expect to see a
message and that might percolate from up
inside some program that I didn't write
but it still means there was a failure
all right by me some real failures right
they're not just things that might
happen all the time in the case in the
course of database programming yeah
there are real pharaohs elseís limit
alert the user to that there is solution
that if you can the examples the first
and second third and fourth are exactly
same query and they have different
behavior that's your problem
what do you mean I what are you talking
about we example number one we generate
messages number two we generate failure
objects as the output then also for
building knowledge I'm sorry
also for building knowledge no I just
said you know we can say something that
the anti distort got a missing
sympathizer property or something and so
every time a property is missing you
call a function and if there is a
function defined and the user can put on
whatever he wants if there is no
function defined then we generate
failure for the entity store and so like
but but you can also have the missing
behavior that is happening in in the
built in and we have a matter we have a
thing called missing behavior we have an
option called missing behavior which
deals with what happens in in the query
function applied to data set right
I'm making sense yeah and it makes sense
to have that for an entity store I think
the default behavior for an entity store
should not be to generate a failure
object it should instead be to generate
a missing in the case where it is a
query that's happened that is analogous
to a standard knowledge base query
making sense yeah let's so what you're
saying is that the first two examples in
the notebook should return both for
missing but if that happens on one
database then they return failure
I think the only way to justify this
mess is if we have an option in the
entity store that is different there is
no option for understand so okay so the
question is you told me that okay right
now we have so the issue is whether to
poison okay in the case of database
queries you're saying it's a single
database query that the whole thing
compiles to a single database query if
something goes wrong inside that
database query you poison the whole
thing and return failure right that's
what you've been proposing yes okay okay
now in the case of the built-in
knowledgebase it will not get as easily
poisoned because it is how it's
implemented is a different story but
conceptually it is not a single wrapped
up database call it is something
accessing the knowledgebase and some
parts of it could fail to resolve and
other parts of it do resolve right so we
do not want to poison the whole thing by
making sense if you ask for you know
properties of you know if you ask for
properties of chemical elements well
okay here's a question so you ask for
properties of chemical elements you're
asking for I don't know what the the
melting points of all chemical elements
right and the physicists on this call
know that helium you know it's standard
temperature and pressure doesn't
solidify right so what that returns is
missing you know not not applicable or
something before the melting point of
here right now are you proposing that
that that there could be a situation in
which you poison everything because
helium doesn't happen to have a melting
point there's no no no no no what I'm
proposing is it were trapped like for
example look that example in that
example you're trying to sort take
largest is the same as sorting by a
property that doesn't exist engineer
already have a symbol missing affecting
you we're not returning something that
has the shape that you expect so that's
not a missing that's a failure and in
the second case we silently return a
result that doesn't make
we'll run in shorten so we'll just take
the first three and they around me
return okay so wait a second so what
you're saying is Antoni you need to
apply on this you're claiming that there
is a distinction between missing values
and malformed queries of some kind yes
and by malformed we mean that you're
asked about see that's what's a bit
subtle because in this case here this
foo thing is like a request so so there
could be two different things here one
is you're requesting C that's just not
right you're requesting a name let's say
that there's a property GDP per capita
right and you know but you request GDP
per goat instead of GDP per human capita
okay and there isn't a GDP per goat and
so then the question is but you've
requested five properties one of them is
GDP per goat the question is what should
happen
should the whole thing do you think that
there's a well-defined way to do this
yes nobody is it's just that it's
inconsistent with what we've added so
there is this missing query and long
property is a failure logistics here
okay I have to go for 30 minutes I'm
gonna change my next meeting you guys
are gonna go on talking about this
without me and I will be back in 30
minutes okay and so then we reschedule
otherwise no we cannot the rest of the
week is completely full okay so we're
gonna have you go and talk about this
file for now I will come back I have
another half hour after that
I think we can move you have to really
think it's important just that there's
me and Tony and do you want me to take
over sharing Stephen yes in a moment
okay um and then then then I'll be back
in 30 minutes but but there's a lot of
interesting stuff on our live stream
here someone will take a quick look at
it um let's see some people are
interested in the entity store and
entity register functionality they were
asking about that there's also something
here that doesn't seem to be working but
Carl had sent us a something that looked
like it was a link but doesn't seem to
be a link um
so which is a wiki data accessing wiki
data through this sparkled system it
seems like that's cool and creates an
entity store for anything that wiki data
knows about that's cool it's a good idea
um can I create custom entities from my
own data absolutely yes absolutely yeah
I answered that's the entity store
entity register yes plus of course you
know this functionality will let you
connect to databases to chat right right
this functionality to be clear for
people in version 12.04 ality is
read-only so if you have an existing
database you can connect to it and you
can map it into an entity store um you
can also create your own entity store
but that is being done as a as an
in-memory entity store um in this
version and subsequent versions you'll
be able to get it done also with an
outside entity outside database um the
um okay
well that's that's some um ok lots of
interesting things that alright I'm
going to disappear for 30 minutes then I
will be back
and I'm sure you guys will figure it out
a lot of good stuff by then do I need to
push these things back into the
repository for that yes before you go
okay let me do that um and in the main
topic of discussion in with a continue
about the the failures to message system
missings well and then we got to go back
to that entity thing because we got to
finish that too so if you have a chance
to look at that that would be good but
first the failure stuff I'd like to get
a crisp proposal and second of all then
we're gonna need to turn to you know
redoing the entity page so if you can
look at that
oops that's a problem um and then
aundrea kisame just notebook it's I'm
sure it's on Dropbox but that's gonna
take me forever to find yes okay I will
be back with you soon okay so I I mean
since we didn't manage to do that
properly the first two and second two
are doing the same thing they should be
unified can you guys just walk me
through this one more time like yeah so
that's nice right right this is the
current behavior of entity value so this
is completely the current behavior for
Tony's right functionality this has
nothing to do with the the database
functionality and that's currently
returning a missing in this anybody
saying that that should change I even
saying should be a failure okay so your
argument is that Carlo I mean there's
nothing missing about that I'm just not
sure I'm gonna everybody's opinion right
so you just this should be a failure
right
and this anybody disagreeing with that
okay so that's Michael disagrees anybody
else you're disagreeing based because
it's changes existing functionality or
other reasons no I disagree with this
that like if a failure for me is
something that just absolutely isn't
possible
on a theoretical basis you request a
file that doesn't exist we could easily
add a poverty food to country and then
it would work
it absolutely out impossibly well but
the problem is slightly hidden in this
case by the take largest which looks as
if it's still a kind of a you know
second argument or something but it
actually is a combination of two
operations which is shown but what does
this do doesn't give the same type of
failure to be consistent these guys
should be doing three randoms entity
okay so this design if the same sort of
doesn't exist
that isn't what you think and everybody
thinks this is okay behavior simply
example would be like what is true of
Holland we define poverty yeah
but-but-but Michael I think what we are
trying to push forward is the
distinction that basically if something
wrong happens in the first argument of
energy value it should fail and what
happens in the second meaning the
properties then it should be missing
that's just as simple as that
but Michael what should your simpler
example fool of Holland yes fool
foreland how do you do that how do you
make it make it the entity entity
Holland it's called the Netherlands so
country Netherlands forget yeah and now
applied and now we want the value of the
property food
so look foo yeah or goo yeah that's
that's that's fine that's the second
argument of entity missing so that
that's fine to write assistant is
anybody's claiming that this should give
a this is totally fine because one
person should that give a message you
know I don't think so
because it might be appearing in cold
somewhere and the user might not
there that he's always getting the same
value
I actually don't buy this argument is
quite seriously about informing music
users of all intermediate steps when
something is kind of going wrong you
know I think that would like it should
not be too noisy right so there's a
president for instance read list of a
non-existing file it gives a message and
returns failed but that's what that
one's designed way before we even hand
the failure objects yeah but the
question is what changed in the
understanding since then that what we
are trying to push the duo from language
a lot more as a general-purpose
programming language rather than
something that's using an interactive
environment and I think it's much easier
to program I think that consensus in
this discussion is that lots of messages
are not super useful right I mean
because programmatically yeah right you
want to get these missings and these
failure things because you could then
you can say something like you know X is
that and then if right ahead of X right
and I think these engineers to say that
this case of the Netherlands is the same
as the case of Antony valuing c-class
fool because yeah Mike Michael was just
trying to give a simpler example yeah
but what I'm saying what I'm saying is
that the main difference is that when
you make a mistake like that where you
put either Michigan - you're missing
property you can always return something
that has the correct shape in terms of
lists of lists but with some points
missing on the other hand in this case
an T class of population I am expecting
a list and I got a missing L so if I'm
mapping over this it says I am already
screened yeah is it fair to say that
regarding just messages I mean those are
mostly useful for when you're
interactively programming something
right like like say yeah like a five
line you know five or ten lines sell
right you're evaluating it and something
goes wrong I mean then messages are
useful like Seraph
intermediate yeah things going wrong but
the problem was the message is that
people starting to use them as a you
know try to build their error-handling
based on messages and messages are
non-local they can come from all the
depth of the execution stack they will
pile up and then people have to somehow
collect them and that's I mean there are
whole many issues of messages when you
try to use them as an error handling
device you're saying it's inviting bad
programming oh yeah absolutely yeah also
think about the fact that let's fish
check does not stop evaluation when it
finds a message its evaluate and then
return something different you mean
using check as a yeah if you like check
one over zero semicolon print it will
still print so that it's okay to return
I mean it's not relocated at admission
but but at least it should be consistent
if you're saying if you are sorting by a
properties that is thick largest of
three you will expect the scheduler
don't create and on property three
random do you generally agree with that
that the check is bad programming versus
no it I think useful programming if it's
pet I don't want to comment I'm not
saying that check is bad programming I
think that check is absolutely fine when
you're doing something like symbolic
manipulation and also the fact that you
know things might be fine
I think I teach a kiss check check is
extremely useful they are on to a
billion queries forms theory and and
twelve something was formed because of
character including issues so check is
the perfect thing to want a huge amount
of things say literally billions and
just get a couple printed out so you're
picking up on right yeah like that
there's some random error message that
comes from the depth of the system and
you're using check to gonna affect us
okay all right on the other hand you can
use check very wrong if you could check
around the whole list before you map
then it will add the first figure it
will not stop
from the list also there is also
defunded when you're getting a message I
mean you only get the name of the
message you don't have any metadata
associated with for example in your
example of encoding the message is just
telling you that there is bra encoding
inside the message that is still the
encoding that is utf-8 whatever or
whatever else right but you cannot
really pass that now the the failure is
a sign but it's much more complicated
right but just wrong just to go back to
this one for just a second here the I
mean Mike my concern is I I think I
agree with Michael because I think if we
change this and we're changing the
behavior of these functions and there's
it's a backward incompatible change so
I'm a little bit concerned about yeah
but you know that's exactly why we raise
this issue right now because right now
the karma would be still limited but if
we allow this to exist in this way for
longer then it will be absolutely
impossible to change this behavior later
and so now is the time to decide right
right but but I mean these are not
experimental functions anymore these
have been you know these have been in
the products you know for who knows how
long like since version 10 I mean I have
some sympathy to that this is not quite
perfect what happens right right right
but my point is that these functions
have been around for so long at this
point that if you change that you know
people may have built entire you know
like programming castles on top of this
and you know like really bad to change
that I mean yeah I mean my suggestion
would be just to do like other people
are doing when when those kind of
changes have done we are saying that for
one major release the missing behavior
for built identities is still there but
we issue a message that from version 13
is gonna start reserving failures and so
people have one major release to look at
the messages and and and fix their
application so there's a desert some
from a user all right what do we call
this a hey watch our stream stream
what's your person called Seoul UK let's
see
identifying possible semantic errors is
pretty tricky I agree but to think about
the UX the worst the worst possible
outcome is viable outcome with
semantically workable input root cause
is critical unfortunately these are a
little disjointed from our discussion
now but does anybody want to comment on
this like I interpret it right but when
we were saying about messages and things
that were like why I personally disliked
messages I think it's a similar reason
that when something happens when you use
exceptions you bubble up the stack
immediately the root cause and you know
don't you don't really hide it by
continuing executing and piling up other
like you know subsequent reasons why
like why why functions higher up in the
stack starts to fail mm-hmm and that's
clean because you don't have a side
effect you simply say okay you've got a
plot point where you can't continue the
normal execution anymore or raise an
exception and catch it later it's
directly okay so so in this example I
mean what's what's sort of the root
cause right you can we say that I mean
yeah so we are looking for a
non-existing property in the context in
which it kind of ruins the entire query
so what I mean this missing seems useful
to me because it kind of tells you right
it's none none okay it's incompatibility
would anybody disagree with that could
also be a failure I don't think so
because for uniformity I'm wondering
that all of those missing unknown entity
missing unknown property whether they
could all be failures in the right place
and memorize in the right place means
if in the first argument of any value
it's probably what you suggested there
is any missing property being used then
there's a failure and if in the second
argument the property or one out of many
properties is wrong then there's a
failure in the right position and should
like should this fail because this seems
to like be very happy about no does not
go away to anything ever ever ever okay
yeah so once where it goes wrong in the
code basically right position rights but
you know maybe you have two T's right
like I think I don't think so on it is
like you take a polygon and the first
point s7 coordinates the second point
that's 15 there's nothing wrong
fully good not even though they give no
error the our happens many a function
that does something this is not object
okay
so this is these are similar yeah even
though this can possibly ever work in
another function okay the thing itself
it's just an inert object okay can I can
I say something about what kinda said I
mean to me the line is if you ABS if you
are able to return something that is
structurally correct in terms of lists
of lists or associations and so on then
you can put missing where appropriate if
you are not able to construct the
correct structure of list of lists
then you should return that's colored it
makes it now impossibly complicated
because like in this case you know the
result would be structurally of length
three so you expect a list of length
three misses no and that's why I expect
a failure there but if I can miss dr. B
thanks three what if there are fewer
countries I'm not saying that you don't
know the structure but if you look at
the example where instead of take
largest you put greater than three then
that's an example where you don't know
what
length would be but it doesn't matter
whether you know or don't know that the
length is three the only thing that
matters is that there's no way you can
construct a whole meaningful thing and
so that's why you're returning a
monolithic missing instead of returning
a list of three missing or so that means
using is that a failure can be the
outermost object but it can't be inside
an expression yes that sounds reasonable
but but I think guys I think that the
rule is as I said before very simple if
something goes wrong in the first
argument it's a failure if sorry
learning it's it's actually not entirely
correct because you can have the list of
entities where one of the entities is
not married in the first argument or you
can have an entity let's say one day we
have computed entity property classes in
that case also you cannot reconstruct
the from structure so it's not first or
second argument it's more whether it's
like one of these objects that
represents list and you can't really see
your desired result for entity value of
two entities comma one property and one
of the entities invalid yeah a type
entity then you can put all the
Netherlands sorry aunt in value and then
put Netherlands in the list that the the
yellow blob in list the yellow blob
Netherlands sure what is like a value
piece the Netherlands Bob from the other
notebook yep and then you can put
something like entity aunty fubar
I got ya and then comma close square
bracket close race can cut second
identity value put Papa nation so what
this does is I think what it does right
now is absolutely fine so this will get
the population for the Netherlands but
of course at t4 has no population and it
does something yeah it says I think this
is totally fine and and the right so we
I mean then the question is what what
happens if this is failure right like
that would be weird right yeah yeah I
think it would be weird it was like for
example missing Hugh has a level
specification and these things as a
level specification failure Hugh doesn't
and we don't have any failures so it's
either either it's gonna return this one
oh it's so distant current behavior this
is the behavior that nobody likes or
there will be some failure some sorry I
I don't think there is any three turn
failure here also when there's a single
unknown entity and a valid property then
you also would still get an missing
unknown entity yeah I mean let me switch
back to awesome some comments yes things
that I want to change is query a new
property okay so we have one more
comment from Seoul UK if people are
trying to evaluate or integrate courses
of action or treat the assessments as
viable then you risk losing all
credibility not entirely sure anybody
want to comment on that you see the
second one is actually pretty
interesting and more or less in lines
with what well let's focus on the first
one first if I'm having a hard time
parts in it same here okay so so UK if
you want to maybe clarify that to school
there are a lot of non-native English
speakers here I think everyone okay
simplify for us we're not very smart III
m2a1 not entirely related but true
air-handling uses failure using failure
is vastly preferable to message pretty
much new it's everywhere grace anybody
want to comment on that one well that's
pretty much the rephrasing of the point
that I was trying to make and then he
expands on his own comment later in this
next to message like like okay yeah like
yeah things returning failure are useful
because she can actually take action as
opposed to right if it returned some
random expression that you have no idea
what and also yeah and also you can
return you can switch immediately and
raise an exception and bubble things up
but I think in general we have this idea
already since forever in the language
that low-level things that are usually
used as programming stuff return we
always return dollar field rather than
issuing a messenger let's take a look
here whenever I issue a message I also
throw a failure I can bubble up okay
well since I wrote my error handling
framework like six months ago which I
don't think I've seen it yet is that
something that Sun gets up or is that a
I'm not familiar with this error
handling framework from before Steven
returns I have one more question for
clarification from their database group
hmm I know if you could write take your
yellow entity block Netherlands yeah
that's right a list of two properties
one valid and one invalid so something
like a list of so yeah yeah whatever
something evolution okay yes that's
mistyped correct and and that one gives
you a list of lengths to know so now the
question is what if instead of a invalid
property you put there an entity
function that makes use of an invalid
property is that a heart failure or is
that the missing in the right place or
what is it
example you mean like wrapping something
around it let's say put in the second
argument after lin e comma V of X very
where exactly yeah there remove that and
right there and any function entity
framework function X X comma and then X
yes so it is just yeah and this is just
trying to extract the property for you
know make maybe maybe squared x foo
maybe square that thing the Brahma is
that at least in our current
implementation we can work it all to a
single query which will obviously fail
so for us it will be a total failure on
the other hand if you start from this
principle that you su can build the you
know regular structure in this case at
least potentially you could keep
returning what is currently returned so
it's kind of an edge case for which
right now I don't think we have good
answer from database side one proposal
would be that by after analyzing all the
entity functions that you're using if
one of them contains invalid things you
place missing in the right place and say
entity function that used invalid
property or something similar yeah but
imagine for example that the failure for
this entity function comes from a
database side or some reason yes yeah so
the problem really is that while this is
formulated in this way here when we
execute this we first convert it to a
query which is a single query and if we
follow this logic then this wrong
property will invalidate for us the
entire query so do we have let you mean
like talking about these examples now
well I mean
examples are different for for Tony but
they're the same for us this is okay now
here we're also using an entity function
just like that using a property that
doesn't exist and then there's the
filtered entity class which is the Neo
function in 12 right yeah and the
question is what what should this return
right yeah I mean for filtering it's
pretty obvious from our side that this
is a failure for the entire query yes I
think that could be true for the rest
too it could be if you decide to okay
yes I mean strictly speaking you're just
constructing an expression and if it
doesn't happen to be true
well it's filtered out but we could be
stricter than that I mean there is also
the question like for example at least
for us even in MySQL it's it's very
different different when you have a
missing not available which is a null in
SQL and when you have a missing because
the property doesn't exist so for
example if you write an entry function
that says missing Q of X fool
that is what is that is that it's not
the same missing as it has missing
population it's it's missing because
it's like an invalid key yeah so I just
want to see an example of actually works
because not so this one this is right we
have a filtered entity class for country
right we want to we want to filter on
population say it's bigger than 300
million I don't know if you need a union
there so what do we need a unit there
Union tried try it how many people okay
so but this is so she discus messages
then or should this give a failure thing
so
it's people like that that peek over the
cap top here there I think that the real
problem here is that as soon as the new
of these queries move to the alpha side
it's gonna be I mean we're not going to
see the messages we also might want to
do the same type of optimizations that
we do for SQL and so it's gonna be
easier for people if we just return the
big failure and you're saying what
should we turn the failure here like
because it looks like filtered entity
class itself is just one of those inert
like you know polish any value any value
should return a failure but you know you
see the question is if if we can compile
that so that it's completely evaluated
on the other side then it becomes more
complicated to generate all these
messages and I haven't seen our behavior
it's easier to say you know like we have
similar there on the agenda notebook
there is a similar example when I try to
some string to an integer in SQL and and
we fail with the with a message that
says something about the type being
wrong each one I said it's the second of
the new comparable function that errors
just what yeah so you're doing plus two
which is the bad thing I presume
yeah I don't know you probably need to
register dentist or the entity store
from go to the documentation page of a
filtered and see class it's the third
example it's there it's in that register
here this is it then we had scroll below
you can only did wherever you want
what is it sorry this is
so what does this mean I now have DS now
you have these new entity types that
company SQLite okay so this will work
yeah I mean it will not work well let's
do one that works first your sorry yeah
I'll try just yeah try instead of string
name yeah first name and then student
join it with who so these are all the
first names and then there's the last
name as well yeah okay so these are fine
right yeah you can do things like first
name last name or something yeah you can
string join them so far so good no
there's no issues with that yeah the
problem comes what do you what happens
if there's an error that's yeah it seems
like so so right now it's missing it's
actually a total tree and this one is
similar to what we had earlier which
would increase density class and unknown
property query something like this one
Michael what do you think about this one
I mean a system should this be a failure
or is it just i mean missing seems wrong
to me here because it's not returned if
you don't have something I'm sorry so
far missing has been our power time but
we returned when we don't have thumbs
yeah but this is not we do have
something this is perfectly fine we're
just doing something really bizarre with
the trend I would say we don't have
something well why
does then interpreter return failures
like it could be that you know next
version we had linguistics for Italy in
Mandarin Chinese and then interpret
country totally different for me okay
interpreter goes from one domain of
things like natural language strings to
entities we are already fully in the
language good perfectly without me I
don't know if you've been listening when
it's we're still on the topic of you
know like Michael is of the opinion that
you know and I'm a little bit with
Michael and says that we don't want to
you know these these are existing
functions and I'm a little bit you know
wary about changing their behavior you
know to failure can you summarize what
you've figured out well we've we've just
looked at a lot of cases like to to see
what the best thing you know what the
best thing is the first question is are
there any cases where when something has
gone wrong
we're either returning missing or
failure is that a true statement at the
current time or other cases where
something grand mostly return on
assessing Briggs are mostly rich in the
existing functionality we never return
failure yeah you might think we ever
return on evaluate 'add mm-hmm
I think we're trying to get freedom that
okay so we return miss on we do we
return messages at this time
that there's some sometimes in case here
where there is the general feeling about
messages is that people don't like them
because they're kinda you know that
they're hard to deal with and they're I
mean our users commented on that as well
that you know the returning either you
know returning either message miss
or failure is better than you know just
spewing out listen listen we don't want
messages without a symbolic failure
return so all missing return very I
think that having messages in addition
to that this team is worthwhile why do
we not want that I mean otherwise you
get the situation as I said before we're
a symbolic function will ingest the
output and you will never know that
something went right I don't think
anybody object objects to debts you mean
I mean I would not object to having
these I mean that they're useful those
messages in particular come not from the
database system I mean those come from
something different those are
consequence and those messages will be
hard to switch off yeah but you can at
least correlate into it no no no I
understand but what I'm suggesting is
that we actually have a message in the
case where we have some messages but not
all messages we actually have messages
um that indicate that something's gone
wrong so now the question that I think
is still apparently unanswered is ok so
the claim that was being made before I
had to go was that there is a somewhat
bright line between those things which
we can be considered missing and and
partially not there
yeah and things which can be considered
failures where it's a great big splat
and nothing could be determined I think
Michaels argument is you know he
considers system it like a proper
missing thing and other people are
considering this a failure thing like
he's saying that if you do this right
something goes wrong nothing is returned
and so forth you know
therefore missing is appropriate so but
ok you know I would claim that invalid
query is on the failure side of what's
going on missing like the field just
isn't there would be I would claim more
on the missing side of what's going on
but the question is can we make that
bright line adequately right God Allah
has a proposal so my proposal is that
whenever you have something where you
can return the meaningful struck
that is like you're selecting a bunch of
entities and one doesn't exist you can
cook the machines inside so that's this
this case right that's that's fine
but when when you have something that
where you would expect I missed out but
you can't generate list and you have to
return missing a known property queenly
that should actually have urn but but
the problem is as you drill down in that
explanation it's going to fail right
because you say take that example on out
thirteen right the over the out the
external structure is okay but the
internal structure you'd say well it's
two quantities oops it isn't two
quantities see what I'm saying yeah so
but I do take your point that if the
thing is at the top level structurally
incorrect then returning failure is a
meaningful thing to do if it is
structurally correct then returning
inner missings makes more sense it is
true that this is a kind of a corner
case that cannot happen for us this will
just splat completely but in this case
where you have an entity function yeah
well fine I got it I got it I got it I
got it
also there are other cases as well like
operational error in the database the
expression can be structurally totally
fine you're talking about the input
expression I'm talking about the output
expression oh I see okay okay so okay so
I think a provisional hypothesis says if
we if we cannot return a struct a
top-level structurally correct output
then return failure if we can return a
top-level structurally correct output
then return missing okay corner case if
you have a single entity value the thing
you would normally return is some random
quantity or something like that should
that then return a missing or should
that return a failure well I would claim
what's that just this case right no it's
not that case it's not that case what's
a good example says that wait wait wait
to be clear it will be that with the
population as only the proper population
thing I think these
being anything it's just a okay so hold
on hold on hold on hold on hold on yes I
agree with you but but now so my claim
is that the so this is a case where it
isn't it it is what we might call as if
structurally correct that is we would be
if this would correctly fit into some
structure were there a structure to fit
into whereas if you put something in
there that would otherwise give invalid
query that can give no guarantee that it
is structurally correct because the
query was invalid yes yes the corner
case I still sees number thirteen yes
that's something which is structurally
correct but it has some valid syntax
deep inside an entity function thank you
like this Oh hold on hold on I
understand so but that is saying unknown
property it's not saying invalid query
why it says invalid t squared
I mean it's know it says miss unknown
property it doesn't say anything about
invalid anything just like you're just
getting notes um this is because of how
it's implemented in the in-memory store
for us it will be an invalid query for
database
okay but I mean okay but my point here
is I mean okay but so what you're saying
is if you did this in the external
database thing this exact same thing
okay so let's say it wasn't Netherlands
country it was an external database
entity right so here okay
we have we have an example here so we
can get run through those example okay
so give an example where it's invalid
right yeah okay so down there and the
last line 24 the like line 24 24 okay so
what you want to do is in that entity
value so it so that's one case none copy
that copy that input copy that input
copy the hole in the hole yeah I'm
working on it I'm working on it and
we're okay and I'll put a list in the
second argument of entity value a list
in the second argument of entity value
yeah okay have the existing energy
function comma well and then have some
valid entity function some something
valid as the second yes yes yes yes yes
give me a second give me a second give
me a second key music like that yeah try
that okay now so what you're telling me
is in this case because of the
implementation this is batching those
together in a single database query
correct yes yeah I mean we could I mean
since we fail way before we send the
entity query we could actually not fail
on the on the second one and hold on so
you are in fact going back on something
you were saying earlier but let me just
interpret this for a second okay
so my claim is this can either return a
failure object okay
or it can return a list where the first
element of the list is a missing
know what I'm saying so in other words
dependent on implementation it could
return one or the other of those things
in other words it either returns
something structurally correct but with
the missing inside it or it says the
whole thing was invalid I'm just
returning a failure
yes that's my claim now this idea which
I'm not convinced about that the the
thing that's inside when it is
structurally correct at the top level is
a missing rather than a failure that
doesn't feel quite right to me
in other words the statement that now of
course things like delete missing um
would you know the useful case there
well I don't know if it's the useful
case but but one can imagine that when
the thing is structurally correct that
it is meaningful to say delete missing
when the thing is structurally muddled
then you've got a bigger problem on your
hands
and we don't have any delete failure
right we don't have delete failure but
and I can imagine a case where you map
over a bunch of databases and you just
try and do something on each of them and
some of them get failure and some of
them don't but I think that's a less
common case than the case where the
thing is structurally correct but some
of the data is missing or or in this
case but okay so how do people feel
about this solution some people
understand the solution no repeat the
solution please okay then then give me
my screen back I was going to type it
okay I want my screen back okay so I
gave it back okay okay all right okay so
so my claim is that
ah okay let's say complete output is
structurally incorrect
okay then you would get failure right
understood so that comes about when eg
database is not connected you know
implementation batches everything and it
fails hmm okay okay so the second case
is a top level of output and I don't
know what top level really means is
structurally correct
am I making sense okay so I'm claiming
that case should give actual output with
missings in it mm-hmm that is my
proposal okay there is one corner case
here which is you have something that is
like that it was input 13 on on our new
screen which was the case where you have
something where it's actually a syntax
error that you're doing in SQL let's say
but only on as part of the thing so that
was you you he was squaring a missing
property how should that feel what I'm
saying
look where was that this is this is oh
maybe I'll know you have to send me a
notebook
it would be the case we're missing is
squared or something like that Stephen
like this like missing squared or
missing plus one you know like something
went wrong in an intermediate step and
in it you know something bizarre happens
yeah well that's a question whether
missing eats everything just failure eat
everything
it doesn't clearly I mean cuz one could
imagine a poisonous object okay but one
could imagine you know okay so this
would be you know what
yeah poisonous arrows right and
determine is a good example of a
poisonous era plus one right so who
missing was poisonous arrows is you
don't know how far to go I mean
indeterminate goes to through arithmetic
I don't know whether does it go through
if I do something like this I think in
America America but I think that the
problem that we were aiming at
discussing was even a little difference
John that was that something that looks
like a totally well-defined input or
actually even output in the original
formulation for us due to implementation
is batched into a single thing you see
that's that's not a problem I mean we we
have an agreement on that the question
is whether syrian type this control
equal yeah
Netherlands or Italy it's shorter open
square bracket amidst population or
soccer team comma entity function X
comma x elgu bracket and then Y and then
put the property doesn't like three and
then you square that yeah that was the
example I think you're putting the
square in the wrong place yeah but
that's what I'm at color I mean for us
did this will completely fail that's one
thing let's consider putting the square
in a different place because I think
that's another case right that's just
evaluated because the student X is not
even recognized ah but it could be
recognized because there's only one part
of the syntax that isn't recognized it's
it's more like sign of seven arguments
no
I don't think that's right I mean the
fact that there's something wrong with
this entity function doesn't affect the
possibility of finding a value for the
population well it's not even an entity
function its power or x or something so
what okay so you're saying it's like if
you used entity property raised to some
power which would but so in what we've
talked about here the complete output is
structurally incorrect so you have given
a third case here which is which I asked
did it happen you said no it didn't
happen which is returning unev al you
ate it
well the two are trying to get rid of it
okay
well so in this case what would you like
it to do I mean I like things to return
none evaluated when you could give a
value to them it you know subsequently
right because it could be the case that
something here is like for example let's
let's imagine an extreme case here let's
imagine this is to the N okay and now I
say % Slashdot n goes to 1 boom okay
that's an argument for having something
unev al you ated if if you could change
something if there's something in there
that that were you to set a particular
value for a parameter it would then
evaluate that's a good reason to leave
something unavailable it yes right but I
mean if you're and this is an example of
that but if you're already toast because
there isn't a parameter to change for
example then you might as well return
something like failure
okay so let's loop back around on this
again okay I I consider that the
difference in behavior between these two
cases is really bad
okay but my already really really
different paint story take a take an
example take a normal function if you
take function of whatever hash and and
then you apply it to two or you take the
square of functions and your flights to
[Music]
okay yeah I understand bracket of noise
please background noise right that
doesn't evaluate that's exactly what I
would expect but that's the case that we
were discussing and maybe this is what
case will be discussing because we're
discussing is like the case where you
have an umlaut in the function hash who
and a new positive Association been an
active or in other words I would I would
call the Anna Maria did sing a syntax
error while the other things are you
already used valid syntax but invalid
content in some sense
that's an interesting return value
that barold hadn't did something
trust him okay so that didn't do what I
might have expected which is to remain
unavailable unfillable slot
okay Tony what we used to just saying so
that we were talking about the case
where you already used to valid syntax
but invalid content while the case of
unevaluated is something for invalid
syntax isn't a meaningful notion because
you know as this example demonstrates
they can be invalid for now but become
valid later they could also become it
could be invalid now something to do
with your data and you re-evaluate no no
this is a bad idea
maybe it's it's pretty common in the
more formal language that you can define
f of X integer integer and if you apply
to a string then it's an evaluated
exactly exactly so I think that case is
correct we are talking about the case
when you already supplied valid
properties well wait wait wait wait
which of these two cases is correct
which of these cases isn't one okay but
in this case you okay so you are happy
where wait wait wait wait you're happy
with both of these cases
no no so we should be talking about the
first one the second is fine in my
opinion the first one the second is fine
everybody's opinion this one here yes
but it remains all evaluated yes I'm
okay with that too okay so what about
this one here well in that one you have
at least in the function with the main
slot you get a message out here we
agreed you're going to get a freaking
message yeah so we've agreed you're
getting a message so don't let's discuss
that anymore
okay okay so output the symbol whether
the symbolic output should be missing
that missing squared
a missing unknown property query
whatever or failure within the list okay
so look the case is that it could be our
blah come
a single missing where it's an absorbed
miss you know a missing which absorbs
probably that's yes right propagated
missing good good term right okay so it
could be this a missing inside or
something with failure or it could be
you know something like this or it could
be a totally poisoned failure okay those
are the cases that I can see yeah I
can't see any oh yeah and actually
missing square it looks really bad to me
anyway well I agree but I think that
there's the the propagation of missing
like indeterminate I mean there is an
argument okay we have discussed this
before whether we should propagate
missing yeah but those were slightly
different type of no no no no no because
the case where it gets difficult is we
have missing blah plus missing foo what
I would say is that in in this case
there are two semantically different
missings one is the missing not
available or not applicable that is
actually stored in the entities that
would be a now in the database the one
is you're asking for something
nonsensical and I have constructed
anything yeah but okay so are you
proposing that the propagation be
different in those two cases
oh no okay so what are you proposing
because oh actually yes I think that the
case where it's like the case where it's
missing because it's an owl on the
database or in the entity table whatever
it's something where you can ask me sink
you and it's interesting to see okay
bottom line is can you square that thing
in other words if it returns as simply
you know a null in the database can you
take missing from the database square no
I I don't think it'll make sense where
do you think it should absorb the square
and turn it into a propagated missing
yeah wait I think there are two cases
one case is like when it's
let me see existing on the database you
might want ask is it missing and so
there is a valid operation on that
missing that doesn't return asking now
but missing Q should do two different
things in those two cases if you're
asking missing you of a property that
does exist but happens to be missing for
some roles then you should say true or
false if you're asking for missing hue
of something that doesn't even remotely
exist then you should probably music so
in other words I think what color is
speaking about is the schema level
missing and data level missing yeah okay
but but either way if this is a schema
level missing are you saying that this
should should propagate the missing and
turn into this I think if it's a schema
level missing it should just refuse to
evaluate the function that's an invalid
like you cannot fill the slots I don't
does it do it returns missing or failure
that's that's not answering the question
okay because what does it do if that
thing was squared
no but it was squared only inside the
entity function you know I know I know
because it made bad syntax there but if
if you could have an operation which
would cause the missing to be squared or
to be added to something else right
let's say inside this entity function
there was something that was bad you had
two nested entity functions and the
inner nest identity function did the
wrong thing okay so you're propagating a
schema level missing what do you do
I would say failure yeah I agree
okay so what you're proposing is what
you're proposing is you're proposing a
sub case here you're proposing schema
level missings schema level badness
would be failure objects and not only a
data level badness would be missings is
that what you're proposing depends
because the data level badness for
example if you're doing total and you
have a hundred thousand things that are
valid and one that is missing you should
probably see a zero so that may be a
different issue that's a different issue
so you know then then we have badness
and aggregated quantities which we
discussed I think in the previous
meeting right about aggregated entity
class
is that not correct I mean that that has
to do with what aggregated entity class
does yes absolutely the behavior in SQL
is going to be different between
aggregation missing and
[Music]
right I unfortunately I'm gonna have to
go I have to come in a few minutes
well one thing I want to add is that
stimuli all badness is I think we can
add two other reasons such as
operational error or whatever because
it's kind of bad I actually don't think
we should treat those two the same I
think we should treat operational error
as yet another level because it's
certainly gonna be a different thing
inside the failure object different
object we already had messages which are
different for this case no it's fine
all right okay so let's talk about um
okay so let's talk about this proposal
right so with data level badness we're
saying in in aggregation missing would
behave quotes would would would dissolve
away appropriately I mean it's a little
odd because if everything was missing
you did a total you would then get zero
yeah and I'm not sure that that's right
either I mean yeah maybe maybe maybe
what we need to do is generate a message
and then make it zero
well I'm maybe not introduced at
behavior unless there's an option to
turn it off which behavior this helpful
missing cancelling well we've already
got this missing canceling
but okay that's a separate thing how we
deal with that okay
so yeah and also still in just to
mention it's kind of consistent with
what Wolfram language does for emptiest
what is well if you compute total of an
empty list you'll get zero and missing a
list of missings is pretty much
equivalent to an empty list also plus
work includes return zero we have M
times open closes yeah yeah yeah okay so
okay in this data level badness do we
expect propagation or not would missing
data not available or whatever whatever
the thing is not available whatever um
would that propagate what would that do
well in other languages it does
propagate through the arithmetic list
to just turn into a missing gate and out
of it yes yes okay all right so the
calculus of missings which by the way we
should involve other groups in but the
calculus of missing that you're
proposing is like indeterminate
propagate through through arithmetic at
least through arithmetic yes I think one
thing you could do is let's say you say
total of pure missingness right you
could in fact decide that that becomes
missing not zero I know that that's
consistent it's probably not because
you're the total is the aggregation
operation yeah well small like it's a
small business for the purposes of total
but I think I think there's not really
such a I mean if you do total of XY is
that that turns into plus in the Wolfram
language so there isn't really a
clear-cut distinction between
aggregation not a negation often
language yeah okay so that's I think
open what that does what that case does
but the default usually should probably
be to assume that missing mean 0 inside
a total yeah okay so that's that's its
own separate calculus of yeah missing
interacting with things like total okay
okay so I just I just want to tread that
in SQL we seen propagates also in string
functions so if you have if your string
giant now with the proper string you get
now okay whatever I am Not sure that
there's the correct thing to do here um
yeah Carl is making the point equated
missing and zero is bad what what about
the standard deviation of the data good
point yeah I mean the fact is we need a
proper calculus of missing for which is
something we should add to the I mean
you know we just have done with great
you know uh oops you know with great
achievement we've managed to do around
what we now need to do is to is to have
a similar concept for missingness am i
making sense right so i think we should
bring that up that's a different group
of people
we should bring that up sort of the the
the the arithmetic of missing so to
speak um okay look I have to go I'm
supposed to give a talk and I I have to
drive somewhere and we have ended up um
taking this to the very edge here but
let's just continue for a second okay so
badness and aggregation is a sub case
here so then um so one possibility is
schema level badness leads to a failure
and
this could be poisonous or not poisonous
Center in this case here there's
propagation and there's poison so
propagation would mean okay so so
propagation is things like well I don't
know whether I don't know what the
difference between propagation and
poison is you know that's propagation
right but this would not be this would
not happen so missing blah comma 22
would not poison that list it would
still stay missing 22 so poison would be
would also do something let's say with
failure if we poisoned with failure that
poison would lead to that happening
making sense it would only to a
structural change
this is a structural change to
well in some cases it will not even
manifest itself as a separate like
failure on a deeper level because in
some cases because we well you can say
because of implementation it will be
combined in a single query the whole
fail I know but that's the case where
it's essentially an operational error we
know that that can happen yeah right so
that that's an implementation fact that
you might get an overall failure if the
structure is wrong yeah but it may look
sometimes more a bit different than like
the third album thirteen that we've been
discussing like when you are requesting
one property which is valid and another
one which is entity function with some
invalid stuff inside that looks like a
structural thing but it ends up being a
single query for us
you
um okay listen I have to go I'm sorry
this is unfortunately not resolved you
guys can continue to talk about it a bit
um
I think our going in a direction that's
separate from this team right I mean
this is a general well yes it's a
general thing and I think that this is I
think it's an important thing which
we've discussed which Roger has
discussed Jose has discussed I think
this is something we need to solve but
we need to solve it for missing rather
than for failure like failure is a much
more extreme splat than missing so my
suspicion is what we should do right now
is try to make a distinction between
things you consider to be failure like
total splat versus missing which is
essentially missing data but does that
mean that we make a backward compatible
change with that case of greater than
three that you have on the other
notebook yes it means yes that's what it
means and yes better that we give a
failure object then that we give
something which appears to be a valid
answer which is just completely wrong I
think we have to consider that simply a
bug yeah I agree I mean we can yet back
out of the I mean it will be good to
leave the structure of the error the
symbolic structure of the error to be
the same you know going forward but I
think it is a much worse crime to to
have something which looks correct but
have it not be correct make sense so
what I would suggest here is that what
we do implementation right now is if
necessary and the database query thing
something goes wrong
okay the database query is invalid um
and and so then
just returned a single you know failure
object and it's just like you're out of
luck
am I making sense yeah future in the
future there will be finer control and
you will get more detailed stuff that
might not just be a single failure
object yeah make sense yeah and it's
also very useful for us because that
means that we can actually actually have
a way to expose messages that are
returned from the database and we nearly
catch before sending that's that's fine
so you know you can make a fairly rich
association inside the failure object
for example also list the reason for
failure which could be like one of
several and people could
programmatically let's find okay so but
that is what you will implementation we
do now but we agree that you will also
generate a user visible message whenever
such a failure object is being produced
and then in terms of what Tony is doing
for the you know built-in knowledge base
I think I would recommend making
basically no or minimal changes right
now because I think that you know I
think we're going to have a new calculus
of missings in the future and I just
don't think we're ready to deal with
that right now but you said that the
first example on the other page should
be yeah if you can return a failure
object for that now fine I would say I
would be perfectly okay leaving it as a
bug for right now because I think we're
not really ready to solve this
okay okay don't break anything we're way
too close to the release to break
something but there is one thing seven
here leave it as it is they're with me
for a second if you leave it as it is we
should at least mention in the
documentation that this particular speck
of returning and missing that what it
does now in that particular place might
be different in the future so the people
don't count on it right now
whatever I think it's just a bug I'm
sorry I don't think we can solve this
right now we're just gonna get it wrong
yes but we have a spec for that which
people read know and they will start
building stuff
what spec for what that in that
particular case where X is equal to
listen if you can make this return a
failure right now make it return a
failure if you cannot we can put it
under possible issues in the
documentation that's about it okay okay
and otherwise you know the whole
structure but what we do need to do is
to spawn off a separate discussion about
the calculus of missing basically which
is a discussion that the statistics
group has been wanting to have I think
now that Hosea has done this very
wonderful work with around we've got a
pattern for how to deal with things like
this I can start a thread on LC see if
you want or l colonel but and it's an
ILD LC c thing i think primarily follow
dos okay all right okay and this leaves
then as a trailing item the
documentation for entity and so on which
sadly we're going to have to come back
to
so get get something scheduled for that
I'm afraid it's gonna be a one-hour
minimum time to sort this out a live
streamed people want to see it um they
we got to give over I you know we've got
so little going on in live streams these
days because we're working on things
that are you know pre-planning for
future stuff and it's not yet ready to
um not yet in a state where it's people
will find it interesting but um yeah so
whatever but but thank you particularly
to folks on the livestream today a lot
of very very useful and helpful comments
and
yes I'm sorry to be so impatient today
I'm just whatever I will now be late for
this talk I'm supposed to give so
hopefully hopefully the audience will
bear with it okay see you guys later
run like right but bye